Seymour and that's a and there Steve and
mr. and mrs. Choi jo j2k hey golf
go to put something in welcome question
well Shannon your mother would those
were my friends golfing friends for
several years now I golf quite often
specially with mr.choi as we call him
mr. chip and now I finally understand
what he says before I would sort of try
on a little bit of Korean that I had and
he would come back met me and and that
was it so I feel quite good there but
you know what I've decided today forget
it you know what I've been at it now for
77 days and I still can't speak fluently
and I've had it quite honestly why am i
putting all this effort after 77 days I
still can't speak fluently what why
bother you know I think that that
language learning it should be that you
just you don't have to study you know
have to work just start speaking you
know and just like or go there or not
early and you should just be able to
start speaking like speak your way to
fluency should just should be that easy
and if it's not that easy why bother is
my view you know and probably if you
make an effort to speak people end up
speaking to you in English which can
which is ignorant in my opinion just
ignorant of them to do that you know I
mean for that matter I mean like why
would I why am I even trying to learn
your language you should just speak
English like anybody that's got anything
useful to say he's gonna speak English
so I I I'm just I'm ready to throw in
the towel like forget it I'm just just
English English or it's just easy just
start talking it it shouldn't be
difficult
like nothing should be difficult
shouldn't be a what that's just you know
like some language teacher with the
power trip as far as I'm concerned
anyway this is all I'm saying
April at first